as the media and their Democrat
compatriots obsess about amorosa or
Michael Cohen or even John Brennan
president Trump is methodically putting
a conservative imprint on the judiciary
and not just on the Supreme Court you
know what I got in we had over a hundred
federal judges that were on a point I
don't know why Obama left that it was
like a big beautiful present to all of
us it was like the gift from heaven we
were left judges they're the ones that
judge on your disputes they judge on
what's fair on the environment and
what's not fair where they're gonna take
your farms and factories away and where
they're not
in only 20 months he's nominated in the
Senate has confirmed 26 new district
court judges and a record 24 federal
appeals court judges with two more
Appellate Court nominees scheduled for
votes this week Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell should get huge plaudits
for making Trump's judicial
confirmations a priority yet
conservatives are still frustrated but
why well because the most notoriously
activists in the most reverse Circuit
Court in the nation the Ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals out west is still
sitting with seven vacancies before
Trump took office the Ninth Circuit was
totally lopsided with 18 Democratic and
seven Republican appointees Trump has
managed to get one nominee through from
Hawaii and another from Idaho is likely
to be confirmed later this year plus the
Seattle attorney was nominated to the
court this summer but still now more
than half of the 13 Circuit Court
vacancies remaining nationwide are out
in the Ninth Circuit and what's more
concerning is that the White House has
yet to nominate anyone for the three
open seats in California I can think of
a few good nominees the reason for this
lies with the time-honored practice
known as blue slipping Court nominees
that's the courtesy of giving a
two senators an opportunity to say yay
or nay to the judicial nomination of a
president going forward and the
Democrats by the way already accusing
the Republicans of messing with this
hundred-year-old tradition which is kind
of funny considering that in 2013
Democrats themselves chose to go what
they call nuclear and ended the ability
of opponents to filibuster trial and
appellate court nominations and what
Harry Reid by the way announced the
change it was all of course at making
perfect sense the rule change will make
cloture for all nominations other than
the Supreme Court majority threshold
vote yes or no the Senate is a living
thing and to survive it must change as
it has over the history of this great
country to the average American adapting
the rules to make the Senate work again
is just common sense
just common sense okay well it's time
for Senate Republicans to use their own
common sense to bust the current
standoff with California senators Kamala
Harris and Diane Feinstein is all these
seats sit empty on the ninth circuit it
continues on its progressive merry way
so is it time to formally ditch the slip
the argument against doing that after
all could be that this could all come
back to bite Republicans big time when a
Democrat wins the White House down the
road and I get that I understand it but
given how the ninth circuit has stymied
key elements of the President's agenda I
think we're kind of past the point of
worrying about Senate traditions the
ninth circuit is completely out of
control from reversing the president's
travel ban last year to blocking Trump
on sanctuary cities it's essentially
been acting like an extension of the
anti-trump resistance there is another
option though that is short of killing
the blue slip altogether and it would
just be to minimize its effect in other
words the views of the home state
senators are still a factor in selecting
judicial nominees but they're not the
equivalent of an automatic veto over any
president's picks but we need to
face facts even if the president fills
all the open seats with terrific
constitutional conservatives the makeup
of that Ninth Circuit runaway Court will
still be 16 Democrat appointees and 13
Republican nominees but certainly it
would be a better chance to have balance
at any random three-judge panel right
odds are better that way and that
wouldn't just be better by the way for
the president or his agenda it would be
better for the rule of law the
Constitution and the country and that's
the angle and it's not just the federal
judges the latest example in that
horrifying case out of New Mexico
involving a remote compound child abuse
and radical Islamic extremists
astoundingly judge Sarah Bachus is
granting bail to five adults in the
abuse case claiming prosecutors failed
to identify any specific threats to the
community
now that's despite prosecutors alleging
that these guys were training kids to
use all those firearms to carry out
terror attacks at schools so how is this
possible